here's what would happen if a
marshmallow hit the Earth at the speed
of light
first the marshmallow would begin to
slam into atmospheric particles as it
entered the atmosphere at the ridiculous
speed it would need to travel to earth
these particles would actually punch
into the marshmallow and stay there so
the marshmallow would gain weight as it
hurtled toward Earth then our fluffy
flying friend would begin to travel at
99.9 percent the speed of light reaching
the surface of Earth in less than a
millisecond if it didn't rip apart from
that highly energetic event the once
puffy marshmallow would hit the ground
with a lot of force take the Chelyabinsk
meteorite as an example this meteorite
exploded at a height of around 19 to 24
kilometers above Russia in 2013 the
overhead explosion injured 1 000 people
the high temperature Journey would cause
the marshmallow's carbon to darken and
Harden converting it to graphite not so
tasty anymore is it so